Lionel Wallace told me that the first time he saw the door in the wall,...
...he was five years of age.
"It was sometime in October."
"I can't remember exactly where I was when I saw the door in the wall."
"The door in the wall was green."
"At first, I walked past it, then I turned back."
"I don't know why."
"I just felt I had to open that door and find out what was on the other side."
"It was extraordinary."
"What was also strange was that I felt I knew the place."
"It was like coming home."
"I wasn't at all afraid."
"There were people walking around."
"They all seemed friendly and happy."
"I saw love for me and for one another in their eyes."
"And then a woman in a dark robe came up to me."
"She opened a large book and put it on her knee so that I could see it."
"There was a picture of me in the poor street with its small, dirty shops."
"And then I realized that I was not looking at a page in the book,...
...I was back in that street, alone and unhappy."